il est arrivé quelque chose
je ne comprends pas de quoi tu causes il
est arrivé quelque chose
ça commence à faire un bon petit moment
que je tourne et même si je vous dis
toute la vérité ça fait 10 ans
ça rajeunit pas mais j'ai commencé jeune
c'est pour ça et oui parce que j'ai
commencé à faire des concerts avec un
groupe qui s'appelait juste à Glott qui
n'existe plus mais les membres existent
toujours depuis 2006 avec d'autres amis
accordéonistes on a créé un spectacle
qui s'appelle fameux bretelles qui
tourne très très peu mais qui est super
quand je regarde ma mère qui vieillit
dans mes yeux mais que peut aller faire
de son rire est lunaire et réchauffera
mon cœur lorsque sonnera son heure mon
premier album finalement il est sorti il
est sorti ça va bientôt faire un an il
est sorti en novembre l'année dernière
et c'est vrai ça faisait ça faisait déjà
sept ans que je que je tournais en solo
entre guillemets parce que j'étais avec
un musicien mais je dis en solo pour
faire la différence avec l'expérience de
groupe quoi et il est sorti à ce moment
là et je pense c'était une très bonne
idée parce que avant et ben j'aurais pas
été capable de le faire parce que ce
disque là je l'ai je l'ai réalisé j'ai
vraiment tout tout dirigé et j'aurais
pas pu le faire il y a il y a 4 ans ou 5
ans parce que j'ai j'avais pas encore
assez d'expérience de studio un matin
j'ai cru voir l'amour il était grand il
était brun il me prenait toujours la
main les jours où j'avais du chagrin
alors j'ai foncé tête baissée droit qui
consolait qu'on a envie de rire je me
repris cet amour-là n'a pas suivi et il
m'a dit le jour où le chagrin s'efface
moi je ne trouve plus ma place cherche
toi un autre compagnon moi je ne suis
que la compassion oui oui bien sûr c'est
autobiographique et mais c'est pas
étonnant en fait parce que quand on
écrit des chansons on écrit avec ce
qu'on connaît ce qu'on a vécu donc j'ai
raconté oui en effet les choses que j'ai
que j'ai
côtoyé ces dernières années et donc
c'était des trucs pas super chouettes
mais au final ça fait un disque chouette
à ma naissance j'étais différente vous
j'avale les yeux fl
j'ai grandi on m'a pris pour un fou
c'est vrai j'avais l'air bête avec ma
grosse tête
les gens y vivent et puis il meurent
quoi et puis et puis comment on
l'apprend et comment on vit avec ça et
comment on fait ses deuils et tout ça
c'est des questions qui m'ont vachement
interpellés et interpellés ces dernières
années parce que j'ai vécu des deuils et
que c'est dur quoi et donc j'avais
besoin j'avais besoin d'en parler
j'avais besoin de faire un spectacle là
dessus de faire un disque là-dessus et
les premières fois que j'ai chanté
toutes ces chansons en concert c'est dur
quoi c'était et moi ça me rendait
vachement triste en fait maintenant je
suis habituée quand je chante il est
arrivé quelque chose en concert
forcément je pense à chaque fois à cette
journée où en effet j'ai appris qu'il
était arrivé quelque chose et mais c'est
pas pour autant que enfin maintenant
j'arrive à j'arrive à le gérer et je
suis zen par rapport à ça je décrocha le
téléphone
pour faire taire cette sonnerie
je reconnais la personne qui entre de
sanglot me dit
il est arrivé quelque chose
je dois te le dire mais je n'ose il est
arrivé quelque chose une chanson un peu
plus gaie un peu plus enlevée un peu
pêchu drôle bah ça fait du bien dans un
disque et puis ça fait aussi du bien
dans le concert et moi ça me fait du
bien aussi dans le concert quoi et la
chanson je t'aime à la folie furieuse la
chante à chaque concert parce qu'elle me
fait vraiment du bien quoi c'est une
chanson super pêchue moi j'aime bien la
chanter parce qu'elle me ressemble aussi
ton nom dans le dos pour toujours j'ai
envie de crier de hurler mon amour
car je t'aime à la folie Furious c'est
ma folie je t'aime ma folie furieuse à
la folie segmenter un petit peu les
choses et pas trop même que vos amis
viennent forcément tout le temps au
concert alors
shooter une chanson je raconte que
souvent les quand il y a des un chanteur
ou un musicien dans une dans une
assemblée il arrive toujours à un moment
où on lui demande de chanter mais sauf
qu'on a pas forcément tout le temps
envie de chanter cette chanson c'est
devenu
tourner ça à l'humour parce que c'est
pas non plus la croix la bannière de
qu'on nous demande de chanter enfin
c'est ça va quoi mais voilà ça me
faisait rire parce que c'est un vrai
ça existe vraiment
la scène c'est différent parce que c'est
un endroit qui est très très libre je me
permets de changer des choses de changer
l'ordre des chansons si à la fin d'une
chanson je sens que l'ambiance serait
plus à faire un petit je t'aime à la
folie furieuse plutôt qu'un petit je
sais pas quand je regarde la mer et ben
je leur dis on fait la folie furieuse on
fait la folie furieuse ils me font ça et
on y va
folie furieuse à la folie j'aime ma
folie furieuse j'aime la folie c'est ma
folie furieuse à la folie
en ce moment je tourne je tourne je
tourne je n'arrête pas je voulais
tourner je tourne beaucoup beaucoup et
puis et puis je
j'écris des chansons pour mon prochain
disque
et j'écris avec d'autres gens et puis
j'écris aussi avec Nicolas Berthon un
livre disque pour enfants sur les
pirates
et on retrouve maintenant un tout
nouveau sujet de la rédaction avec
Johanna Johanna c'est à toi
un titre anglais pour une exposition sur
le cinéma screenplay ou comment jouer
avec l'écran un questionnement ludique
sur le rapport au cinéma l'expérience du
spectateur aussi c'est ce qui
m'intéressait dans cette exposition là
avec toujours un souci de diversité des
champs et des pratiques artistiques et
forcément une prédominance pour la vidéo
puisqu'on parle de cinéma on parle
d'image en mouvement mais on a aussi du
dessin on a aussi des maquettes des
objets on a également de la photographie
on avait des pièces sonores des
installations 11 artistes internationaux
voient leurs créations mise en lumière
dans la salle d'exposition de Guyancourt
parmi des œuvres une fresque géante
réalisée spécialement par la
plasticienne Julie Dumont elle a réalisé
pour cette exposition là une grande
fresque
storyboardée de 4 mètres par 2 mètres 50
de hauteur ou donc elle a elle est à la
passer une semaine à Guyancourt pour
réaliser cette pièce qui va ensuite
intégrer le fond d'oeuvre de la ville un
travail sur craie spontané l'artiste
s'est laiss
et encore quelques dates à retenir avant
de relire Critique de la raison pure de
Kant le 1er décembre Emmanuel baymer se
rend concert au Prisma Élancourt le 3
décembre la malle au sortilèges
présentera ses trésors magiques aux
jeunes publics au scarabée à La Verrière
le 4 décembre Philippe Karm est en scène
le bourgeois gentilhomme avec des
comédiens et des automates à la Meuse
attrape le 7 décembre Ben Mazué plus
volo + soma seront en concert à la
batterie à Guyancourt et les 7 et 8
décembre Roland OSET et Thomas Fersen
présenteront histoire du soldat de
Stravinsky au Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines que vous
pouvez retrouver ainsi que l'ensemble de
la programmation culturelle des salles
50 innoises dans le kiosque sur Internet
aux adresses qui s'affichent ce mardi
sur le
www.qiosque.ski.fr 6 places à gagner
pour le concert de volo et Ben Mazué à
la batterie